thank you very much for that
introduction it's a real pleasure to be
here I'm going to focus a day on showing
you these three just because they're
probably the three leading qualitative
software packages see tomorrow
okay so there's a couple of things which
are nice about working with this
directly is that I can kind of see the
codes down the right-hand side so I've
got some codes which are about branding
okay so that's all to do with the kind
of positioning of the coca-cola bottle
or can and some which are to do with
actions and some these ones in red are
all a kind of voiceover or speech type
code I've got the word risk in the
middle and it's showing me the context
within which that word occurs and if I
click on any of these words here it's
showing me the sentence not surprisingly
the most frequently occurring words are
very close to the topic that I'm
interested in I can also look at it in a
cloud view okay maybe I'm interested in
how the field has changed in my topic
area over time I can do a comparison of
visual comparison over time these are
those new labor keywords that Faircloth
came up with they've all got numbers
next to them I was interested in the
frequency within wit with which these
words were used over time but also I
needed to code for the context within
which they were used because I wanted to
do a qualitative analysis as well as a
frequency count by looking at the
something like this I can see that he's
a lot more prolific in his speeches
immediately after he leaves office in
the first year after then he was later
on